[Music]  officers down in front of the bank  automatic weapons being fired  [Music]  cannot drive  bank robbery suspects have taken an  ambulance i got a cop shot just gotta  get him to the hospital we're doing  hostages now  i came to you for a loan you're my  brother have i ever gotten you anything  that i couldn't get you out of lock  everything down  we're just trying to get home  we don't get to walk off into the sunset  i have a plan  [Music]  police are following these two suspects  just chill out  gotta chill out hit me up  what's going on in there  these guys are nut jobs  [Music]  [Music]  does your wife know your rap eggs  i'm sorry brother i think it's the best  of me  sorry that brought you into this  i just want things to be the way they  used to be we are trying to save you  [Music]  i'm going to get you back home now  brother  [Music]  get everybody home  [Music]  cannot show me up let's not show me up  only in theaters april 8.  [Music]  you